la chronique de l'économie ce qu'il faut
retenir dans le département des yvelines
ce soir focus sur lies commerce l'un des
rares secteurs à bien s'en sortir
actuellement bonsoir clair bonsoir
et oui en 2012 près de 30 2 millions de
français ont acheté sur internet c'est
1,4 million de plus en un an
le e-commerce se porte bien en france et
bien évidemment dans les yvelines
nous verrons les raisons de cet
engouement et les évolutions de ce
marché et ne deux invités vont nous y
aider nous recevons aujourd'hui grégory
tu as l'eau vous avez lancé en septembre
dernier confie ce box un site qui
propose des boîtes surprises de
confiseries et votre société est basée à
trappes est également christian goy ions
bonjour président fondateur d'i graal
votre société est elle basée à la
vieille église en yvelines et elle
s'appuie sur le shopping
puisque vous proposer des réductions et
du cashback avoir le cash back c'est
pour chaque article acheté chez un
commerçant partenaire un pourcentage du
prix d'achat finalement qui revenue au
wall acheteurs ont campé par vous
grégory tu as l'eau votre société donc
tout jeune depuis septembre dernier
le e-commerce pour vous c'était il
finalement une évidence pourquoi vous
n'avez pas souhaité lancer un magasin
physique finalement parce que déjà
historique manger j'ai travaillé dans
plusieurs sociétés du commerce
donc c'était c'était évident de créer
cette société sur internet et maintenant
il est vrai que pour pour acquérir
rapidement des clients pour développer
son activité
le commerce en ligne ça reste le canal
de vente est redistribuée sous le le
plus adapté à mes yeux et aux yeux de
pas mal de nos clients forcément
parcellaire
tout à l'heure vous avez une jolie boîte
verte voilà auquel vous avez un menu et
vous avez dans cette boîte
voilà des des bonbons le but en fait
c'est une surprise une surprise voilà on
achète on achète une boîte de bonbons
c'est parce qu'à l'intérieur on
s'affairait c'est un abonnement et vous
recevez c'est parce qu'il a comme
bonbons à l'intérieur vous ne savez pas
ce qu'il ya dedans c'est la surprise
c'est une surprise tout seul entre 600 g
et 1 kg de bonbons mais personne n'est
déçu personne nous a retourné la boîte
pour le moment personne n'est déçu
justement puisqu'on propose des bonbons
un peu différent des produits qu'on
essaie de source est un peu un peu
ailleurs notamment à l'étranger et de
surprendre un peu nos clients en
proposant des bonbons un peu disparu
type des années 80 voilà alors vous
christophe loizillon votre entreprise
n'est pas une société dit commerçant
soit c'est un portail d'e shopping
finalement votre offre votre entreprise
s'est développée parce que les
e-commerçants vendent bien
pour deux raisons et c'est igraal c'est
d'abord j'ai créé en 2006 donc sage et 7
ans et ça marche bien ce qu aujourd'hui
on compte un million deux cent mille
membres
donc c'est pas un petit phénomène
s'intéresse plus d'un million
d'acheteurs sur internet en france et
alors effectivement pourquoi ça marche
bien parce que on parce que l'on
s'intéresse au e-commerce aux h aux
achats en ligne
mais ça marche d'autant mieux parce que
c'est un système de qui permet
simplement d'acheter moins cher sur
internet
alors on achète moins cher sur internet
en comparant les prix en faisant pas mal
de choses mais igraal propose du cash
back comme vous l'expliqué tout à
l'heure au lieu d'aller directement chez
un des 1300 e-commerçants que les plus
connus en france passer d'abord par
rigal
vous inscrivez tout ça c'est gratuit
sans engagement et à chaque achat vous
récupérer entre 3 et 25% d'entre achats
donc c'est comme une carte de réduction
géante universel mais on s'inscrit une
seule fois c'est gratuit et la
différence des cartes physiques où il
faut avoir une carte par magasin on n'a
jamais dans son portefeuille avec qui
râle on a on s'inscrit une fois et les
réductions sont valables chez tous les
e-commerçants dans les voyages
il se croit quoi désaccord avec 1000
trois commerçants une trois ans
finalement pour eux
quel est l'intérêt c'est d'avoir une
fidélisation plus importante une
meilleure visibilité
les internautes les acheteurs sont
fidélisés iron puisqu'il kull sur leurs
comptes d euros donc à chaque achat il
récupère non pas des points mais d euros
donc entre 3 25%
donc ça c'est donc des utilisateurs sont
fidélisés et violent mais pour le
commerçant c'est intéressant parce que
il a accès à donc un million deux cent
mille acheteurs et c'est nous qui
faisons sa promotion
et il ne nous paye que lorsqu'il ya une
vente il ya beaucoup de systèmes sur
internet où on fait de la publicité on
paye les clics les visites mais y'a pas
d'achat derrière nous c'est différent
xbox ou pas ce que vous travaillez
ensemble pas encore pas angloise encore
ça pourrait vous intéresser un tel
dispositif justement comme l'expliquent
comme explique le fonctionnement 10
graal forcément pour un e-commerçant ce
que vous attendez d'un système comme
commis graal c'est forcément d'un
système à la performance donc la
publicité
jeudi avant même sur internet il ya
encore quelques années vous achetiez du
trafic sans forcément avoir un retour
sur investissement qui peuvent être
mesurés avec ce type de système
forcément c'est intéressant puisqu'on
peut les perspectives qui sont ouvertes
simplement on espère bien travailler
travailler ensemble une fois que alors
votre société fait d'ailleurs partie des
50 entreprises qui défie la crise en
france d'après le dernier classement du
magazine l'entreprise du classement
deloitte
ouais ok on est septième en france sur
la classe et par la croissance qu'on a
fait trois mille trois cents sont 10% de
croissance en cinq ans trois mille trois
cent soixante dix pour cent oui
faire c'était sans d'alice energy vrai
on est passé de quelques centaines
d'inscrits à un million deux cent mille
inscrire et comment vous l'expliquez
est-ce que c'est aussi finalement le
contexte de crise qui incite les gens à
aller vers ces systèmes de réduction de
cash back
oui complètement je dirais la crise
accentue la recherche de bombes l'antre
guillemets et même quand il n'y a pas de
crise utilisez ira les un système de
réduction sur internet c'est de toute
façon intéressant acheter moins cher
c'est toujours intéressant et comme
notre solution elle est hyper simples
pour économiser de l'argent ou acheter
moins cher voilà ça génère du succès
alors vous le succès arrive il commence
vous avez commencé donc du coup vous
n'avez pas de local vous n'avez pas de
faim si en fait si vous voulez j'ai des
bureaux xi qui se trouve à trappes et on
travaille en fait avec avec les êtres
delà de la marsa dans la trappe qui gère
toute notre logistique et et qui
s'occupe de tout où nos envois postaux
donc voila en gros c c'est comme ça
qu'on fonctionne c'est un fonctionnement
simple assez réduit au minimum et on
peut radier en flux tendu et exactement
on travaille à la commande et on
travaille avec nos abonnés qui sont
fidèles en temps réel donc voilà on
stocke pas plus que ça écoutez c'est
plus facile pour se lancer dans une
entreprise de ce type là est encore une
fois comme vous me posez la question
tout à l'heure avec un magasin physique
vous n'avez pas le choix vous avez
forcément du stock vous avez du passage
et c'est alors que là sur internet où
travaillent en flux tendu vous voyez au
jour le jour
comment vous pouvez relancer et ce flux
tendu justement combien de clients vous
avez d'abonnés de régulier il ya la
plateforme alors en fait boxe là on
tourne autour de 500 abonnés maintenant
donc ça me chiffre tout à fait tout à
fait sympathique pour un point démarrage
sans faire trop de publicité sont sans
être trop connu
donc après c'est vrai que nous on
travaille beaucoup sur les réseaux
sociaux donc c'est très très c'est
impératif pour nous qu'on y soit et que
qu'on cible nos clients qui sont qui
sont fortement présents sur ces sur ces
réseaux là et après voilà on va
développer des programmes à la volonté d
qui dit commerce veut dire communication
forcément sur le web
oui forcément forcément après voilà sur
internet on n'a pas de problème encore
une fois à proposer des promotions
pouvoir tester des produits de la
confiserie ce genre de choses voilà les
gens sont à la recherche de bons plans
et de produits forcément différent donc
c'est quelque chose qu'on connaissait
forcément de source et avec des produits
un peu sympa et une offre vraiment pas
trop cher à 15 euros frais de port
compris pour pouvoir tester ce type de
produit fonctionne et si la même façon
avec une communication qui est très axé
sur internet lui ont fait beaucoup de
choses depuis cinq ans maintenant qu'on
est leader on essaie d'aller un peu plus
vite donc l'essentiel aux
investissements publicitaires sont sur
internet
on a aussi un système de parrainage qui
génère qui va générer cette année
environ 100 à 150 mille nouveaux
inscrits les gens se parraine puisque
quand on part elle un filleul on a un
bonus et 10% des cash back de ses
filleuls donc ça peut aller très vite
donc voilà les investissements c'est
essentiellement du web avec des réseaux
sociaux un petit peu tourné c'est plein
de choses
les mobiles aussi cette année
particulièrement les tablettes et puis
voilà des partenariats beaucoup de
partenariats avec des grosses sociétés
de médias notamment
on va s'intéresser à une autre
entreprise justement qui comme vous se
développe aussi via les réseaux sociaux
et politiques a donc en ligne dans le
département des yvelines
on regarde ça en images ici c'est le
paradis des motards on trouve de tout
des plaquettes de frein aux bidons
d'huile en passant par les gants mais
tous ces accessoires ne s'achète pas sur
place mais ici sur internet l'idée en
fait c'est que les gens n'arrivent pas
forcément à trouver les pièces dont ils
ont besoin parce que les petits
détaillants peuvent pas stocker toutes
les pièces pour toutes les machines et
donc il ya une nécessité en fait d'avoir
des gens qui ont accès à beaucoup de
fournisseurs et qui peuvent expédier
partout en france y compris dans les
zones rurales où c'est très difficile de
trouver un magasin
cette société dit commerce fait le lien
entre les consommateurs et les
différents fournisseurs existants pour
multiplier l'offre
impossible donc de stocker les deux cent
mille articles proposés ni de prévoir
les ventes alors shogun moto fonctionne
en flux tendu cette idée c'est françois
qui l'a eu en 2010 se fait donc
longtemps que je travaille dans la
partie moto
l'idée c'est que j'ai travaillé aussi
derrière un comptoir et j'étais toujours
gêné par ces aspects là ne pas avoir la
capacité de faire des recherches rapides
j'avais des clients motards qui venaient
me voir et qui donc avait des demandes
particulières et je savais pas où
recherché potentiellement donc avoir la
puissance d'un outil informatique
adaptée ça permet de
pour trouver très facilement potes dès
le départ il met en place un logiciel
qui permet d'agréger toutes les données
des catalogues des fournisseurs des
pages et des pages a résumé par marc
catégorie ou encore couleurs un outil
sur mesure pour le e-commerce est un
avantage majeur par rapport à un magasin
physique le mois dernier shogun moto a
mis en ligne un nouveau site pour
retrouver ces données à chaque modèle de
moto les pièces disponibles
autre aspect propre web à la
communication
tous nos supports de communication sont
orientés online et on essaye d'être
présent sur tous les endroits où vont
les internautes pour placer notre
communication donc principalement les
moteurs de recherche comme google et
tous les sites affinitaires à la moto
dont tous les sites du parc de moteurs
et les clients suivent le chiffre
d'affaires a doublé chaque année et un
douzième salariés va rejoindre l'équipe
un exemple représentatif du mode de
consommation actuel en 2012 le
e-commerce a engendré 45 milliards
d'euros de ventes directes soit 19 % de
plus
en nommant alors cette offre par
catalogue sur internet c'est finalement
et en services qui ne pourrait pas
exister dans un magasin physique
grégory tu as low as que vous même votre
société pourrait exister hors du web
oui je pense que ça pourrait mais ce
serait difficilement envisageable
maintenant et je pense que après tout
est possible mais en même temps j'ai
envie de vous dire maintenant sur
internet on peut on peut développer
quand même une offre intéressante pour
des clients pour cibler une population
assez rapide a servi l'argent est
utilisé des outils qui sont satisfaits
de vos choix
c'était à refaire vous feriez la même
chose bien sûr après la boutique
physique voilà un patron peut on peut
travailler dans l'autre sens il ya
beaucoup maintenant dix commerçants qui
travaillent dans ce sens là ce qui les
lance maintenant une option internet et
la presse se dirige vers des boutiques
physiques ou ou des points des points
devant tout est le volet drilles fr non
pas forcément
idéalement pourquoi pas si vous me posez
la question si ça peut vous intéresser
je peux faire quelque chose franchisé
fait ça alors qui dit commerce dit
paiement en ligne nous avons rencontré
frédéric lost le directeur de l'adie
e-commerce chez p box alors dès le début
nous a expliqué que les consommateurs
n'avaient plus peur de payer en ligne
c'est quelque chose que vous ressentez
vous aussi les consommateurs payent pas
chez nous mais paye chez les
e-commerçants et donc les gens plus de
plus en plus confiance j'ai
effectivement et les systèmes sont de
mieux en mieux fait pour que pour que ça
marche bien
du coup frédéric l'os nous a plutôt
parlé de l'évolution du e-commerce ou
les coups de 7 ce site internet est un
formidable croissance
il ya aussi des transferts d'activités
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas ignorer que
le secteur voyage à progressivement
quitter les réseaux physiques au profit
d'une réservation sur internet il ya
d'autres segments qui sont très très
importants comme la e-administration
l'ensemble des mairies des collectivités
locales proposent des guichets de
paiement de réservation du type cantines
crèches et compagnie sont des nouveaux
business
mais aujourd'hui nous sommes très
fortement positionnée sur les logiques
de cliquer magasin donc nous allons
pouvoir accompagner un marchand sur son
activité en ligne ou mobiles mais de
pouvoir retirer le produit directement
dans un point de vente et on va savoir
faire gérer enfin si à faire circuler la
transaction depuis le canal internet
jusqu'à un débit qui sera finalement
réalisé au point de vente
vous partiriez également sur le m
commerce c'est des solutions de paiement
pour les mobiles alors est ce que c'est
pour vous un nouveau secteur nouveaux
marchés finalement c'est une simple
continuité du e-commerce ça va dépendre
du du commerçant et du projet des
commerçantes donc c'est certain que nous
avons des pages de paiement qui s'adapte
canal mobile pour pouvoir
en complément de la chasse sur internet
accéder à ces sites par des interface
optimisée
on compte également dans cette
participation les tablettes de type ipad
et autres qui importe le fait de pouvoir
payer depuis son canapé ou même son lit
et de surfer sur le canal internet
il ya aussi des applications qui sont
complètement internet il ya une grande
démarche par exemple les réservations
taxi qui ce sont des monopolisé et
aujourd'hui il ya de plus en plus
d'applications contenus dans d appliquer
enfin de paiement de contenus dans les
applications mobiles et c'est là c'est
un réel nouveau business alors les deux
évolutions pointe et sont le fait
d'ouvrir la possibilité aux acheteurs de
venir chercher leurs produits dans un
point de vente
et puis le m commerce alors grégory tu
as lot concernant ses points de vente
est ce que vous êtes d'accord ou est ce
que vous pensez plutôt que ça ne peut
marcher pour que pour des grosses
sociétés qui peuvent hors du coup des
points de vente un peu partout en france
bon je connais pas l'offre dont on parle
paybox encore maintenant je pense que
pour des plus petits commerçants comme
nous je pense que dans un premier temps
c'est pas c'est pas forcément la chose à
développer tout de suite par contre hui
tous les tous les créneaux qui sont
liées au m commerce mobile tout ce qui
est optimisation de sites liés aux
réseaux sociaux où ça c'est des choses
qu'on va qu'on va faire après j'ai pas
je pas persuadé que pour nous en tout
cas ça soit ça soit un axe de
développement premier à faire en tout
cas au niveau de la société christophe
diot voulait le m commerce
c'est quelque chose que vous essayez
développer oui et d'ailleurs on sort une
application mobile est pour pour mobiles
et tablettes qui a du cash back intérêt
donc des réductions sur intégré dans le
directement dans l'application
ça marche pas encore très bien à vrai
dire le m commerce en france il sait pas
encore un gros volume par contre ça
marche bien
enfin dans notamment les voyages
réservation d'hôtel les réservations de
train les réservations de vols ou les
enchères donc là ça commence vraiment à
décoller ya un business significatif
effectivement le mobile c'est exactement
et puis voilà exactement
et puis il ya un petit démarrage aussi
qu'on observe dans on commande sur
internet
on va chercher effectivement dans la
libre dans le dans l'alimentaire en
particulier ça commence mais bon je
dirais que c'est encore marginal très on
va finir sur vos perspectives pour
l'avenir veritas le peut-être oui bien
sûr va le développement du mobile comme
je vous disais pour nous c'est assez
important
après on va voir si on peut on peut voir
on peut voir avec des partenaires de
qualité en termes de paiement si on peut
développer des choses un peu un peu
santa là dessus puis toujours les
réseaux sociaux et à permettre aux gens
de s'inscrire maintenant très rapidement
sur le site pouvoir commander très
rapidement dès que livrer encore plus
rapidement donc voilà on va on va
essayer d'optimiser toute cette chaîne
là le développement d'israël va déjà
qu'on est numéro nous sommes de numéro
un en france et réductions sur internet
c'est de le rester de le rester
normalement de doubler dans les deux
prochaines années donc à passer à plus
de 2 millions d'inscrits je pense va
commencer à être significatif en france
puis on a aussi ouvert l'allemagne qui
commence à décoller voilà merci à tous
les deux ce concept éclairage autour du
e-commerce et du m-commerce si le
commerce sur mobile merci